who would you rather work for liverpool  football club or the conservative oh my  goodness gracious he's falling off the  chair oh  do you know something i have to say  a hundred percent  liverpool football club  enjoy something you know how much i  don't like them  but you're something i look at jurgen  klopp jordan henderson they're the two  leaders in that club at this moment in  time on the football pitch and off the  football pitch they're good men they're  good people they're honest  let's start with that shall we as the  basic sort of fundamentals of a leader  in this country and move away from what  would be the sort of shenanigans and  shambles that we've had for this last  six months you've just got your headline  gary neville wants to join liverpool  thank you